bonjour tout le monde
c'est
pour nous
non sans déconner d'alice
exclusive
et on se retrouve aujourd'hui
pour une nouvelle vidéo
commentée voir en finale
donc pour cent alors là me
direz-vous à ce stade-là de la
vidéo mais pourquoi était-il
impliqué auprès
commenté sur 24 alors qu'ida
dit que je l'étais pour lui
humecter tout simplement
parce que pour ça je ne suivrai
pas fait je suis quelqu'un qui
se lassent
ultra rapidement
bg c'est pourquoi donc imaginer
sa marraine aperçu de côté
et puis là je me suis dit
pourquoi ne pas
pourquoi jouer tv c'est
d'apprécier le jeu les agents
tentent d'amorcer je voulais à
m'entraîner à un collègue m'a
piqué mon petit prix
en gros le monde
dites-vous que voir une portée
par la vidéo à un seuil
critique qui est fait sur la
personne âgée détendez-vous
et avec cette vidéo de
l'événement dans votre tête
avec ça
ou pourquoi les monades
houcine pour les alcoolos enfin
bref donc c'est parti donc c'est
en démolition sur l'amas de
jeunes c'est plus long
parce que je ne citerai pas le
nom de madoff
backup serait donc c'est parti
pour cette partie est une bonne
partie dans le sens
outre c'est vraiment jouer
stratégie voyez donc lâché
ses couleurs pour cent pas
pour ma part ça complètement
foiré pour le moment les
évacue tout au long de la
partie je m'habitue au cours de
la deuxième décennie
donc là je me souviens que ça
reçu par l'afp agence de cet
excellent technicien nantais au
peuple sang
% en fait moins que je vais tout
de suite que la passation de
surdité
je trouve que c'est plus
difficile d'accès selon moi
la robe j'entends quelqu'un qui
avance me retourne je vais tuer
je voudrais pas que je sois à
fond dans mon cas ce cas c'est
vraiment un chien on entend le
mot but but but donc c'est tout
de suite repérables
et donc plus que prévu et les
factures
donc c'était lui parme
un peu déçu si je vois même
pas stable
enfin à quel point notre
prière je suis c'est monstrueux
si votre sac à 47 a su être
très très très joli
moi je disais donc ma classe
c'est pour ça qu'à 47% le ca
du t4 dans le gard légale pour
les blocs l'afp avec la tour
grands chargeurs
axelle 47 et si les grands
chargeurs par chargeurs boîte %
après des études secondaires
elle mange
rc genk adressé
en forme après avoir vu sa
surprise de voir son gagne-pain
elle montre que la france et 38
dossiers saisis donc ma place à
quelqu'un en sait plus
distinguer
j'exagère améliorer comme à
tous j'ai pris qu'un équipement
plutôt j'ai pris pour cet
expert ex ante
t cruel
un restaurant mais là je
souhaite pas surfer sur le web
studio
le gérant du mal à vous
retrouvez donc l algérie un peu
plus tôt devant mon ordi ces
faits à base de terres rares a
offert un petit retour en
arrière on va chercher les
serveurs
oui dix capsules sur le coude la
vie
donc je disais donc e que matoub
marathon
% jc puis
dans un tweet
bourgi sécu
qui est un marathon et le dge
c'est plus à faire ça c'est
sûr
donc donc la mangeoire attaquer
donc j'ai plutôt vu en fait
cela a vraiment envie attaques
sur arnaud inclus
parce que si vous laissez pas
jouer l'objectif est donc je
commence par l'ansés gaspiller
les grands maîtres comme ça
gratuitement c'est vraiment
triste pour ma part
%
donc finalement voilà je vais
plutôt aller sur paris
sachant que des plus difficiles
d'accès comme dit tout à
l'heure par cela
de plus il a fait son commando
du circuit hama centre sans trop
de difficultés dans l'euphorie
là-bas ils sont deux
j'arrive à avoir les deux
beaucoup ne pourra pas reporter
les parents roger lemerre
e parce que tout simplement ce
match il est donc on voit pas
mais en fait pour cent du projet
vedette
sur le tarmac revoilà donc là
j'ai mis en place leurs spots
donc je comprends fois la
dernière en barrage mais les
scousers faire enfin bref
donc la technique va vraiment
être en championnat je leur dis
qu'ils foutent de nous prendre
bac
un ou deux buts ou pas être
2 des sites débuté via les
libéraux chère au nucléaire
% sachant que la f rance pour un
appât
je veux que les gars et je ne
sais pas ce qui se dit dans une
vidéo qu'il était vraiment une
grosse pub tête
% photo police traite égyptien
et en parlant de tapette %
mathilde d'espèces de pour
françoise à sortir la semaine
écoutez plutôt
si ces transferts entre clubs
bien encore croire à la ramasse
des gens
qui partent à la chasse au
trésor c'est pas croyable
il court partout sur la map les
attendent que vous le pouvez
quelqu'un mince poli un petit
voyou polémique sur la main
puis il court il court il court
il court il court
alors que la colère divine qui
l'a chargé de la ville les
marques en fait
vous avez pas voir où je
l'avais mais pour cent dans
l'âme radars étaient
brouillés et donc j'ai mis un
peu près sur la page du sundgau
et j'aurais dû la mettre sur
pied
c'est la rentrée pour ma part
en plus des futures de personnes
froissart monde
les personnes par jour
mais j'ai eu très très chaud
mais j'ai quand même réussi à
avoir
cet accueil car on sait qu'il a
trouvé comme on dit un peu
parce qu'elle a pas trop de
recul pour s'en aller à ses
frais six pièces et plus tôt
voilà toutes les qualités pour
une bonne arme je trouve
dans le cas où je suis je suis
pas en attaque c'est vraiment
pas beaucoup joué les objectifs
jd ciné
les amis faire escale à
marseille après la défaite
allah
on va faire la manche
donc lui un gros stress l'avenir
kifaya
je continue mon chemin vers le
milieu de la matinée à trouver
un emploi parce qu'en principe
être là-bas il passe au mieux
donc j'aime qu'un peu regardez
là-bas
jeudi j'ai vraiment beaucoup
aimé jouer la stratégie de la
fed partis flamands un pur
bonheur d'habitude je je vais un
peu n'importe quoi et si la
chance se réveille
ainsi encore eu lieu
le fameux avec 547 au revoir
donc faire l'achat par la russie
de la mort à hama tarder
m la fois défende pas
uniquement pour jouer sur des
formes avancées en amont très
stupide de ma part
%
donc la forteresse intrus
stratégie que je le fasse parce
que c'est beau ça pète
j'ai complètement loupé
complètement loupé
la marque volkswagen a fait
état de palestine pour cela
aussi que j'aime beaucoup je
suis toujours facile je suis
très actif comme ça
enfin bref c'est la dernière
des dvd et des fusées
nucléaire
pour san rafael de 3 me fait
beaucoup penser à 27 ans auteur
du tube de renfort de très
beaux ces quatre courses de la
fin 3
mais air france m'a fait
vraiment penser à 7% à cette
arme-là de modern warfare 2 que
j'aime beaucoup et si jamais je
refais une vidéo commentée sur
mac os pour tablettes peuvent
être déduits de la fête des
jeunes qu'on fait une sorte de
roulement
et bah écoutez je vous
montrerai quoi
il montre au second set sa
maison
pierre belloche partout
un vote ont gagné ou pas je
vous laisse la surprise donc là
c'est en défense et c'est
vraiment là que je vais et je
trouve vraiment bien joué ici
donc là encore une fois faut
que je retrouve le bon joueur
pilier de civisme
c'est moi qui joue quoi
surprendre mais je le redis
l'ajout au début j celui
trouvé très vite du multi
contre comme ça
pourquoi
dans le jeu est beaucoup plus
j'ai vraiment très envie
d'écrire l'une des plus belles
forêts s'est amélioré par les
blagues
de petits voulez
c'est vraiment parler stratégie
donc tout avoir pour
conséquence avec des collines
des péquistes égal avec le
plus vite possible au début la
marque polémique
c'est incroyable que l'on s'est
fait prendre le ballon satin
impressions je m'en sors plutôt
bien et tracter une sorte bien
donc là je sens que je vais
passer ma part pas comme
d'habitude c'est défend pas
la technique réside dans le bac
à penser ça me faut vous
faussez d'eads en 2008 et des
prendre part le dos
effectivement très respectée
donc s'ils ont acquis le
deuxième je n'ai pas eu je
crois qu'on aurait pu pour
recharger
pas vraiment je conseille ça
pour être à ta ma vidéo
dresse sur le tutorat des
facteurs là j'ai posté
aujourd'hui tout à l'heure
si nécessaire je crois qu'ils
sont en vie ou plus
si c'est vraiment ça fait très
plaisir cette misère c'est
vraiment génial
et je vous invite à aller la
voir si vous voulez vraiment
mettre les choses au clair entre
les flashcodes les coûts
structurels
si vous voulez apprendre un peu
comment les faire compliqué
j'entendais les balles de set et
revoilà je pense qu'il me
manquait une balle pour la voir
il a préféré assurer son
coût lié au couteau
paralysée j'ai stoppé
terra membres
j'entends quelqu'un qui amorce
elle a même eu en regardant je
l'entendais je ne sais pas
pourquoi je ne suis pas
retournée d'été ils ont
acquis une très bonne
stratégie
les corinthians posées à notre
allié à la finale de la coupe
c'est comme quand je m'attendais
vraiment passé
à la rentrée
% comme je connais vraiment mal
et maintenant vous allez voir
que l'on va alors je me suis
fait unique film dérivé vers
détroit et demi et je me suis
pris à froid
entraîné par la chute des prix
à la consommation ont baissé
plus que par le passé quand
quelqu'un
à voir paris ap toujours un
petit malin pour venir souper
préparé leur coup
donc là ils étaient tous âges
légaux rosemont bien stoppées
pour cent et ce lors des phases
seront même qu'elle se fait
remarquer en voir par où il y
arrive
c'est vraiment très intime
la route lance m
cet enfant
chamaa sébastien viseur laser
très bizarre takashi par
noureddine espèces d'arbres de
doubler les gamins de servisair
donc là en principe les petits
malins que les autres et
s'exiler à faire péter hart il
faut passer par là logiquement
regarde-moi darlas
devrait passer par la migros
défaut dans tous les clubs ici
c'est de ne jamais presse
presque jamais regardez nos
radars jugement des autres
administrations c'est affreux
or et argent du mandat lors du
sommet du g20 le savoir
donc si c'est pour aller de
d'espèces déjà sortirait
pourtant la semaine
dans la semaine
si j'avais eu l'idée d'inviter
deux amis pour la faire dormir
chez moi le soir mon sens en
foot c'est ma vie pour biarritz
non je suis méchante
mais pour cent en finale je
pense pas que ce soit possible
de le faire tout seul et de la
gela frais vers minuit pour que
j'ai encore plus peur d'être
daté de demain sur les petits
sur le dos
mitchell
donc là je regarde plus
ils veulent pas nous prendre
part à notre côté là où
dans ses objectifs a cassé tout
ce que je sais c'est très
possible en principe les gens
aiment bien faire ça
la part des états fédérés
dans la partie quand même
là je me suis plutôt bien
sortir vraiment je suis surpris
je suis très surpris car dans
cette partie il n'y avait pas de
lancer un coup de pub les gens
étaient vraiment
c'était vraiment cool ne
sortait pas des armes de
nouveaux liens franchement les
gens étaient tous
c'était assez agréable que je
dois bien dire j'ai pris un
certain plaisir à jouer dans
cette partie
car à la pause mans l'a
vraiment mon ami m'a très très
bien comme ariane qui a soutenu
et ça fait très plaisir
sans rien
le deuxième article apporte
quoi
la scène textile balancer
harrachis pas pourquoi je ne
sais pas moi toute seule
écoutez pourquoi j'étais tout
le temps
au lendemain de la fin 8e
ça allait vraiment sur le
devant le stade de l'aube
devant
s'il allait vraiment sur le
devant de sa kippa soldats
la fa cup
excusez-moi si ce soit face à
la fin seulement c'est vraiment
pas de la fota va maintenant sur
les faits
excusez-moi si je parle très
vite comme ça mais c'est
pas de ma faute parce que c'est
de ma faute
mais en soi c'est pas ma faute
parce que c'est une habitude que
j'ai pris
qui a entraîné la mort jafar
renvoi
débarrassé de ses transactions
je remercie
monique herment et les autres
neuf clubs de l'élite
la forêt privée
je remercie tous prix
toutes ces heures difficiles je
pense pas
pour moi c'est vraiment super de
la part de fonds propres mais
ça fait vraiment
très plaisir d'écouter en
moins de six jours j'ai gagné
près de
le coût de 39 d'abonnés
société
39e
ah ça fait vraiment vraiment
vraiment très plaisir ma vidéo
spéciale de son abonné n'a pas
été beaucoup plus
sûrement parce que les gens
dans la marde de deux coups de
gueule de youtube
ils s'amusent pas taper
vidéo le turbo boost aux yeux
bleus
forts de leur savoir-faire
les drs pour passer de petits
aaah il était en train de le
conquérir plus important
la charmante et qu'elle fait
partie des 42 pts
donc là je vais vous parler
je crois je crois que c'est ça
qui va se passer je vais sortir
dans ces cas voilà je me
retournais là
surprise à la plage le sifflet
facile ça c'est vraiment
dommage pour moi j
sur l'amendé et je regarde mon
cher mais seulement l afp
affreux
en effet le savoir par je ne
sais quel miracle
les femmes on voit la première
manche si vous avez décidé
tottenham et vidéo des
critiques des conseils
respectives des faits et du tout
cela renvoyait tout toutefois la
baisse qui sera dans la
description j'ai exclusif @ mais
ils pourraient faire un effort
% vous savez maestra depuis que
je fais vraiment servir des
vidéos stadiers un peu près
depuis
le coup
trois barges 3-2 trois marocains
moyens
oui un mois et demi et j'ai
déjà 230 aux abonnés
je trouve ça vraiment mai
extraordinaire racheter si un
jour j'arrive au village vous
ferez des 10%
il a en revanche pas réglé à
la démarche peu assurée comme
coupe-faim
là or j'avais un mandat
d'arrêt est passé de côté du
but je regarde à gauche at-il
encore rappelé
j'ai beaucoup lu le public
d'ailleurs être arrivé à un
peu la jellaba
ensuite vous allez voir à
nouveau arriver je vais avoir
beaucoup de le cio
savage plainte s'appuie sur un
plan de match trop tard m
pas assez prendre la tangente
hortefeux
j'ai réussi à se développer
j'aime vraiment et là je vais
maintenant pouvoir
malheureusement fait leur temps
je suis content
lafarge était lancée là je ne
pouvais plus m'arrêter là
vraiment
et la mrh ne pas comprendre
pourquoi mes objectifs proforma
ça regardez
pourquoi je me disais les
premiers comme ça parce qu'il
avait été expulsé
ce débat-là l'isie
pour écouter les experts ces
vidéos à l'appui
un double cliquer sur j'aime ça
dure
vraiment plaisir c'est à quel
point
abonnez-vous et c'est encore
mieux ça fait vraiment plaisir
si vous voulez vous aussi
en fait
les décideurs de l'ue
l'attaquant chasse comme ça
pour les abonnés à faro
on veut pas un plan b pour se la
péter mais c'est vraiment parce
que ses dires des gens nous
soutiennent c'est ça qui fait
personne ou presque tous abattus
à sion
aussi que j'adore les jeux et
que j'aime bien de vous
présenter
dangereux
et puis voilà donc on se quitte
sur ce magnifique essai
tu sais pas ce que je fais
enfin bon bois lacté salut tout
le monde je n'attire sont dans
un instant je vous remercie
d'avoir vu la vidéo commenté
les pays qui soutiennent
abonnez-vous
et voilà tchao tout le monde
bye merci encore
la séance de lundi
football
désir
suite
c'est bon